i'm gonna give you some esca
oh there we go
[Music]
frank josephine pizza wars is back are
you ready i can't wait gonna be a lot of
fun people coming in here a lot of tasty
pizza i think i might have to walk my
ass back to brooklyn over the bridge
because this is going to be a lot of
carbohydrates
last season i was on a quest to become a
master pizza maker
frank our first episode i learned a lot
from you that was genius and joe oh my
goodness we had to do that deep dish
together i know crazy those are two of
my toughest battles but now i need your
help as you guys know i started off
making pizza right out of my house in
rockaway queens i'm a home cook at heart
but now i'm looking to open my first
restaurant right here in manhattan to do
this i really gotta bring my a-game and
come with a full arsenal of incredible
pizzas for my menu and that's where you
two come in as this season's judges
panel from episode 1 throughout the
season last year i watched you progress
this season
me and joe
we got some new challenges coming your
way we have some wonderful chefs coming
through we got some different styles and
techniques and i think it's really going
to push your skills to the next level
nicole we love you i know but we got to
keep things fair and impartial indeed so
this season something a little new we're
gonna do a blind taste testing so in the
end we're gonna crown a winner okay i'm
ready bring it on what do you guys have
in store for me today so it's the first
challenge of the season it only makes
sense to bring it back to the beginning
and we're going to be making pizza
fritta you know here in new york we
don't see that much fried pizza but it's
actually one of the world's most
traditional pizza styles so for today's
challenge we got one of the best out
there there's not many people that are
going to give you more of a fight than
georgia from don antonio george is no
joke
but you got this
nicole you ready i'm super nervous but
you know what let's do it let's go
georgia thank you so much for being here
what are we making today thank you so
much for a mini goal today we're making
montanara oh
and what exactly is montana montana is
fried dough with the tomato sauce smoked
buffalo mozzarella basil and pecorino
romano i know fried pizza is huge in
naples right yeah so what's the
difference between pizza fritta
and montanaro so
in naples the most popular pizza is fry
the big difference in montanara is we it
just fried dough and we put tomato on
the top the pizza fritta is filled but
that is the biggest difference but fried
pizza is the most popular and one of the
oldest pizza that you can find in naples
yeah so let's go i can't wait to try
your pizza i can't wait you to try your
pizza okay let's go
so first step i have the dough over here
and i push really gentle
on the crust so next step is just to put
the pizza
inside the oil oh look at that
the color that you want is gold i don't
want really
brown color because that is too much i
use sunflower oil
that is created in bologna in italy so
georgia you come from a long line of
pizza maker i mean your family is like
embedded in pizza culture did you win
like one of the top awards or the top
awards yes in the world so i won a
competition in nables when i was really
really young with this pizza oh my
goodness with that very pizza yes okay
now i'm nervous
oh my god this show keeps backing me up
they keep setting me up
okay so the dough is out of the oil so
what's next georgia so now i'm putting
inside a pan and i put the tomato sauce
one spoon is the right amount i think
for everything and i put basil like that
on top of the pizza and now i put this
milk buffalo the cheese
and in the end the pecorino that is good
perfect good you can eat right away but
i want a little bit more crispy so i'm
gonna be put in the pan and put inside
the oven that is my secret okay you
heard it here first
it's ready let's take out
oh it looks so good yeah oh my goodness
i love the color
so you can see the crust is really
really more crispy it looks good time to
dry all right i'm ready
cheers thank you so much no thank you
all right let's see
oh no this is amazing already
i can tell
this cross is
sick it's just remarkable the texture is
amazing the inside is so nice and soft
like
if this little crust was bigger i could
just fill it with like some salami and
provolone
and make me a little sandwich
it's so good this is the first time that
i do
you know montana in the home kitchen i
think i do really good you did good i'm
actually sitting in my head going oh my
gosh i gotta top this
i'm happy that your pizza came out so
good because it's a challenge yeah thank
you again thank you
job thank you let's see what i do i
don't know
i think you do the best ah thank you
well let's see before i cook my recipe
let's head to naples and learn about
pizza
[Music]
[Music]
so georgia your pizza was delicious but
this is what i'm making for you today
pizza fritta but guess what i'm filling
it with
scot roll oh my god i just had to say it
like that
people say that along with the escarole
i'm also gonna use buffalo ricotta
but what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
season my ricotta a little bit i'm gonna
add a little parmesan to it and i'm
gonna put a little lemon zest in there
i know that italians refer to escarole
as
money
yeah so i was like oh money i gotta put
money in my pizza money is good luck
right you are the queen oh please
you guys are always so nice to me i
don't even know what to do
anyway so then now we're gonna put a
little bit of olives in here
and then i'm just gonna put a little
meat in there
now we want to close this bad boy up
and we want to make sure we seal it real
good i saw people hitting it since i
grow up i see pizza fritta like clothes
like that you know how and how you layer
is perfect well thank god because i just
was using a little common sense yes so i
was like you know
for this reason i say you're the queen
oh my lord so i just dropped this in the
oil and what i'm doing is i'm pouring
the oil so the top could get nice and
golden too and also just spreading a
little heat i think right we we called
the bath of the pizza because my oil was
pretty hot
in it you like it yeah
so i know a lot of people are to say
she's not making pizza she's making a
calzone what would your response be to
that
canzone is a pizza it's a pizza as well
right yeah it's just different shape i'm
just going to cut this because i really
want to just see the inside yeah i'm
just anxious you know usually you would
eat it you would hold it and you rip off
the top and it'll be like in wax paper
but i just got to see what the inside is
absolutely you can eat the way you want
okay cheers
[Music]
oh my gosh is it good very good oh no it
is good wait hold on
oh my gosh this is delicious
and you can eat from inside you can take
this part and
i would definitely serve this at my
restaurant
game changer wrong and you know what's
so good about a new york restaurant with
this
it's still street food pizza fritta it
was making the street eat on the street
so for me it's a street food it's so
good i have to say
as you know it's not up to us
we got our judges today wow frank and
josephine wow and this season i'm proud
to say it's a blind tasting wow okay
they will not know which pizza is mine
they will not know which pizza is
george's maybe i'll win maybe i won't
but you know what i have to say i never
lose on this show because it's an honor
to sharpen steel with the best for the
best the best
[Music]
wow all right this looks like a calzone
it does look like a calzone i usually
love fried calzones
all right
it tastes like a zeppoli needs a little
confectionery sugar
brown paper bag there you go
shake it shake it this is good
it's really good the the dough is nice
and airy and fluffy this thing is big
it's heavy yeah this is this is heavy
it's like this is good for a couple
meals but it's delicious it's hot so it
feels like it just came out of the fryer
it's got a nice crispy outside
this one has some beautiful like
browning and even a little charring on
it it's delicious it's really really
good it's it's a lot different than what
i thought we were gonna get i'm really
liking the uh kalamata olives they're uh
a little salty yeah and they bring a lot
of flavor to the ricotta cheese well
while i'm eating this
the joe is so good what is that a little
shadow in there that's what i'm thinking
my only real criticism i would have to
say is that i'm more of a minimalist
myself um i like things that are kind of
stripped down it was a little smaller
maybe had two of them you know you could
always wrap the other one up put it in
your backpack and save it
you ready for the next one oh i can't
wait
oh
very different that is very different
very different style this feels like a
pizza you know what i mean this feels
more like a slice
[Music]
all right that's got a lot of flavor
yeah it definitely has a lot of flavor
smell that ramen smell some smoke right
the sauce is delicious the ingredients
are delicious
the cheese looks like it melted a little
bit weird though it wasn't cooked enough
but at the same time they probably just
didn't want to burn the crust it's not
like a regular mozzarella though it's
not it's a it's a smoked mocha yeah you
could taste it that tastes nice it
tastes like it was barbecued a little
bit just pizza
i see the smoked mozzarella i see the
the way that it's done in a very more
traditional italian style i think the
first one
what makes that not a calzone who says
the sky is blue everybody's got their
own interpretation of things people make
pizzas in so many different ways so i do
agree in the traditional sense
this is a pizza
we just had two great pizzas they were
both pizza fritta in their own way we
gotta choose one how can it be hard i
know i agree with you a hundred percent
although i'm gonna tell you what i'm
thinking
[Music]
[Laughter]
george and nicole
we had two amazing pizzas today as you
can tell there's nothing left
this is a really tough decision it was
just so awesome to work with georgia
today but we got to know what you guys
decided
both pizzas were delicious but they were
very different right the first one that
we tried i love the way it was wrapped
up it wasn't broken at all it was just
like a beautiful piece of golden dough
you know on the other hand the second
pizza that came although it was minimal
it it packed a heavy punch you know what
i mean like they did i also really like
the escarole and the other one the
shkadov
with the kalamata that was really good
so we talked it over and frank is gonna
go ahead and tell you what a win is go
ahead i'll leave it to you yeah so the
winner is
[Music]
the montanara we chose the more
traditional looking
round pie just because it represented
more of what a pizza kind of looked like
and felt like to us but you guys are
both winners in this one so i'm not sure
who made it i have my guesses but
jonathan
nicole you made a fantastic pizza it was
banging thank you everything married
each other it really did yeah like i'm
i'm super proud of what i created but
you know absolutely georgia did a
wonderful eye like he did a wonderful
job thank you thank you thank
you good job
what is that smoke muchuratla wasn't it
yeah okay and and was that
escarole
i had so much money
i'm gonna give you some escott oh there
we go oh [ __ ] oh we win tonight
no more trophies only money
[Music]
thank you so much
everyone thank you nicole it was a
really amazing day and amazing
experience
i meet you know new friends and daddy
was amazing thank you so much this was a
hard challenge right out the gate i've
got my work cut out for me this season
but i'm ready
one down
more to go to win let's go
get it let's get it
[Music]
you